all right afghanistan let's talk about
afghanistan i hope you'll forgive me for
not beginning the show with afghanistan
there are there are other things
in the world that are that are happening
that are important
like again the extinction of our
civilization kind of an important thing
um but afghanistan is also happening so
we're going to go through some of this
this isn't even going to really be five
headlines this is just a jumble this is
a ball oh headlines is what it's really
going to be is that a bunch of things to
cover here we'll start i guess with joe
biden
you've probably seen some of these clips
but worth playing again he was
interviewed by george
uh snuffleupagus on abc
and this is the first time that joe
biden has taken any questions on
afghanistan these are the only questions
he has not given a single press
conference about it
or he's given things that look like
press conferences but then he shuffles
away
uh before you know answering any
questions about it so he sits down here
and he he
to allegedly answer some questions
but what he has to say is
we are used to hearing unintelligible
things from this man
but this is far worse than you would
even expect let's listen
when you look at what's happened over
the last week was it a failure of
intelligence planning
execution or judgment
look i don't think it was a fail look it
was a simple choice george
when the when the taliban
let me back and put it another way when
you had
the government of afghanistan
the leader of that government getting a
plane and taking off and going to
another country
when you saw
the significant collapse of the top of
the afghan troops we had trained or up
to 300 000 of them just leaving their
equipment and and taking off
that was you know i'm not this is that
that's what happened that's simply what
happened but we've all seen the pictures
we've seen those hundreds of people
packed into a c-17 we've seen
afghans fall
four days ago five days ago what did you
think when you first saw those pictures
well i thought was weird we have to gain
control of this we have to move this
more quickly
we have to move in a way in which we can
take control that airport
and we did
so you don't think this could have been
handled this actually could have been
handled
better in any way no mistakes
no i i don't think it could have been
handled in a way that there we we're
going to go back in hindsight and look
but the idea that somehow
there's a way to have gotten out without
chaos ensuing i don't know how that
happens
i don't know how that happened so for
you that was always priced into the
decision yes
the only thing
that was honest and made sense
of all those clips you just heard
is where he said i don't know how that
happened
i believe him on that he doesn't know
how anything happened
the process by which he ended up sitting
in that chair talking to the abc
reporter he's not he doesn't know how
that happened either
it is not an exaggeration to say this
man
literally cannot complete a sentence
i mean am i wrong was there one full
sentence uttered
he starts to begin a sentence and then
kind of trails off and cuts himself off
and then goes off in another direction
some of this is that he's scrambling to
come up with excuses and he's panicking
um but then a lot of it is also that
he's 78 years old and he has dementia
turns out
that having a dementia adult
alzheimer's patient for a president is
not a good idea who would have thought
turns out it's not a good idea
let's can we agree to not ever do this
again the thing is we can't agree even
after this experience
we as a people are so collectively
stupid that we can't even agree like can
we agree that we're never gonna have
another 78 year old president ever again
we're not going to try this experiment
again
we can't
um
he says uh he says
it's hard to really analyze what he said
because again there was
almost nothing coherent there except
when he except when he confessed that he
has no idea what's going on
uh the bit about how it was four or five
days ago when people were falling off of
airplanes
i i i'm not sure what he was actually
going for there what what point was he
trying to make
and of course he's got his friend
interviewing him and he's so he's not
going to follow up he's not he's he's
doing every the the reporter george is
uh stefano stefo uh snuffalucka
snuffleupagus whatever his name is
he's doing everything he can
to help joe but he's asking questions
but he's doing it he's not gonna follow
up on a question
where the answer was that embarrassing
that was four or five days ago
yeah and what's your point
first of all it wasn't four or five days
ago when he gave that answer
i can't imagine joe biden
if he was ever accused of murder
and he's sitting down during the
interrogation did you murder that person
look that was four or five days ago
what does it matter
there are points you could make about
the fact that people were falling off of
the airplane
now i understand that the visual is
obviously very upsetting
for anybody
um and politically of course it's also
disastrous for the biden administration
and for good reason because as everyone
agrees the whole this whole thing has
been handled disastrously
um but also you you could point out that
um
you know people chose to sit on the
outside of an airplane that was about to
take off into the sky
and it's also very likely that the
person flying the plane didn't know that
you don't exactly have rear view mirrors
that are going to show you that so he
did so
the person flying the plane
let's not put the blame on them for this
they're trying to get out and they're
being swabbed swamped by a mob of people
and so they're worried that this mob is
gonna is gonna stop everybody from
getting out
they've got like 600 people inside that
plane most of them young men
uh so they're trying to get out they
didn't realize that there was anyone
sitting on the outside of the plane i
think it would have been reasonable for
them to assume that nobody would do that
because that's suicidal there's like
zero chance of that resulting in
anything but your immediate death
um so
you know i i think that's a point that
joe biden if he was cognizant
could make
um
he could say listen it's a horrible
thing it's very very sad we can't blame
the people on the ground for that
um that would be fun but he's not
capable of saying that well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content